y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 a continuación les presento algunos
de los temas que vamos a tratar en esta
edición
anuncios muy importantes en eeuu a lo
largo de esta semana la farmacéutica
pfiezer aseguró que con su vacuna contra
el kobe 19 esta es efectiva para los
menores de edad con edades comprometidas
entre los 5 y los 11 años van a pedir
luz verde para que las autoridades
locales les permitan aplicarla en este
segmento de la sociedad algunas
restricciones también a partir del mes
de noviembre podrían ser levantadas por
ejemplo podrán ingresar a eeuu todos
aquellos que ya estén completamente
vacunados y cuenten con una prueba
negativa una pcr esto pone fin
prácticamente al turismo de vacunas
hacia eeuu la gente tendrá que estar
vacunada para poder ingresar a ese país
también hablaremos de la decisión del
gobierno del reino unido- que anunció
que va a simplificar las restricciones
de viaje hacia y desde ese país europeo
a partir del 4 de octubre
va a mantener su lista de países de
colores verde ámbar y rojo en esta
última en la lista roja que es la más
restrictiva de todas está la totalidad
de américa del sur y también buena parte
de centroamérica y el caribe
la controversia radica en que el reino
unido no reconoce las vacunas que son
inoculadas en estos países del
continente americano y tampoco la
emisión de los pasaportes sanitarios una
medida que ya fue calificada como
discriminatoria y hay muy buenas
noticias para américa latina' dos
centros públicos y privados en brasil y
argentina- fueron elegidos por la ope s
para encargarse del desarrollo y también
de la producción de vacunas de la rn
mensajero para combatir el kobe 19 el
organismo continental busca fortalecer
la capacidad productiva de nuestra
región y así reducir la dependencia de
los laboratorios internacionales en un
futuro en otros escenarios de posibles
pandemias y epidemias
les vamos a comenzar el programa y lo
hacemos con las cifras del avance de la
pandemia de kobe 19 al cierre de esta
semana en el continente americano vamos
a ver algunos de los números vamos a
comenzar en el extremo norte del y
canadá superó los 1.6 millones de casos
los fallecidos ya superan los 27 mil 600
mientras que la población con el esquema
completo de vacunación en canadá ya
llega al 69 punto 60 por ciento nos
vamos un poco más al sur honduras en
centroamérica este país reporta para el
cierre de la semana más de 361 mil 500
casos los fallecidos superan los nueve
mil seiscientos y el porcentaje de la
población vacunada con el esquema
completo ya llega al 19 punto 80 por
ciento vámonos ahora a esta américa del
sur venezuela registra un poco más de
329 mil casos los fallecidos superan los
4 mil 363 allí la población con el
esquema completo de seguridad según el
último reporte que data del 10 de
septiembre llega al 14 punto 88 por
ciento y en ecuador los casos superan
los 500 7.000 los fallecidos ya pasaron
a los 32 mil 600 y con un rápido
incremento en la vacunación ecuador ya
alcanzó el 54 punto 97 por ciento de su
población completamente inmune ahora
vamos un poco más al extremo sur en
chile- reportan 1.6 millones de casos
más de 37.000 personas han perdido la
vida por el cob y 19 y como buen líder
de la vacunación a nivel mundial chile
ya inmunizó con un esquema completo al
73 punto 23 por ciento de su población
vamos ahora la consulta con el doctor
carlos eduardo pérez médico infectólogo
asesor científico de france24 invitado
habitual aquí en nuestro programa doctor
pérez como siempre un gusto saludarle un
gusto compartir con usted estas
preguntas inquietudes que surgen tanto
en la redacción como entre los
televidentes de france 24 y comienzo
preguntándole por esas buenas noticias
que ha dado la farmacéutica johnson y
johnson tras un nuevo estudio en el que
dice que su vacuna contra el cubil 19
tiene un 94 por ciento de efectividad en
qué posición queda entonces esta vacuna
que era como una de las más seguras en
el mercado
si recordemos que estas vacunas todas
están haciendo la evaluación de un
refuerzo el estudio ensamblados lo que
muestra es cuando este refuerzo tendrá
una efectiva de 94 por ciento y hasta
100 por ciento para la enfermedad grave
digamos que es una excelente alternativa
porque muchas personas se han vacunado
con esta que es una vacuna de una sola
dosis y con un refuerzo que se haga
entre dos a seis meses después podía dar
una protección muy importante para
evitarla
esta situación de lass y me podría
permitir la inmunización completa doctor
seguimos haciéndole seguimiento al tema
de la tercera dosis este debate que se
ha dado en varios países y la
farmacéutica pfiezer bayón tec y las
autoridades sanitarias de eeuu ya
recomendaron esta tercera dosis bajo qué
condiciones a qué segmento de la
sociedad estadounidense estamos hablando
en particular
hace dos semanas se presentó la
aprobación para que la vacuna fuera
universal a ser el refuerzo es decir
mayores de 12 años sin embargo esta
semana lo que se precisó es que esa
dosis de refuerzo sea para mayores de 65
años y dosis adicionales que se están
aplicando en personas con
inmunocompromiso eso quiere decir que
las dosis de refuerzo en personas que no
tienen comorbilidades solamente está en
ese segmento poblacional de mayores de
65 años donde caen la producción de
anticuerpos es una noticia muy
interesante por que alertaría en todos
los países a que la población que ya fue
vacunada desde el inicio de este proceso
vacunación en el primer trimestre se
refuerce en este tercer y en este tercer
trimestre
efectivamente con una dosis adicional de
facer por ejemplo el debate continua y
son muchos los países que tienen que
determinar cómo van a usar esa tercera
dosis o sea le vamos a hacer siguiendo
haciendo el seguimiento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa para el cierre
doctor un estudio de la escuela médica
de la universidad de michigan en eeuu
o un resultado que no sé si a usted le
parece preocupante el 73% de los
pacientes que estuvieron hospitalizados
en cuidados intensivos han registrado
persistentes deficiencias cognitivas
estamos hablando de delirium síndrome de
confusión agudo y alteración del estado
mental nos tenemos que preocupar por
este estudio por esta situación que
están dando a conocer
cada vez estamos viendo qué pasa con las
personas que se afectaron por cody
recordemos que esta infección es una
inicial como siendo viral pero el
proceso inflamatorio se inflaman los
pulmones los riñones y especialmente el
cerebro y eso explicaría esas
alteraciones cognitivas sobre todo en
personas que han tenido una infección
severa y en cuidado crítico si estamos
viendo en estas personas pues con muchas
alteraciones o algunas alteraciones
neurológicas y por eso es importante
recordar que la vacunación previene eso
algunas personas dicen no yo prefiero
que me de la infección y con eso ya no
necesito la vacuna y no es cierto porque
cuando uno le da la infección puede
tener una complicación y entre ellas las
que destaca el estudio de michigan es
esas complicaciones neurológicas
alteraciones cognitivas pérdida de la
memoria si las hemos visto nos preocupa
y por eso el llamado tan insistente a
vacunarnos para no enfermarnos
generalmente la de esta enfermedad
porque no sabemos cómo este virus nos va
a afectar hemos visto gente con una
excelente salud o una excelente
condición física y que el virus los
golpea muy fuerte
envía durante varios días a los cuidados
intensivos doctor pérez muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en la
consulta gracias por habernos acompañado
como siempre un gusto
vamos ahora a ver cómo está avanzando la
vacunación en el continente en américa
específicamente algunos países de
américa latina para el cierre de esta
semana les presentamos el porcentaje de
personas que ya han recibido el esquema
completo de vacunación vamos a comenzar
en el salvador allí el 50 punto 17 por
ciento de la población está ya
completamente vacunado panamá cierra la
semana con el 49 punto 83 por ciento
está ya a punto de llegar a la mitad de
la población colombia llega al 31 puntos
65 por ciento de su población con
esquema completo su vecino perú llega al
28 punto 92 por ciento y para cerrar
vamos hasta bolivia el 26 punto 0 6 por
ciento de la población está vacunada
allí con el esquema completo
y la compañía farmacéutica pfiezer
aseguró que su vacuna contra el
coronavirus es efectiva en los menores
de edad ya lo decíamos si lo consultamos
con el doctor específicamente en
personas entre los 5 y los 11 años de
edad la compañía ya indicó que va a
buscar la aprobación de las autoridades
para inocular esta vacuna en ese
segmento específico de la población eso
sí con algunas restricciones de recibir
luz verde comenzaría oficialmente la
vacunación de menores de edad en eeuu
podría ser una nueva arma en la lucha
contra la pandemia global el anuncio de
facer que su vacuna funciona para
personas de entre 5 y 11 años podría
abrir la puerta a que más países
vacunarán a los más pequeños
si medimos la habilidad de los
anticuerpos de los niños que fueron
vacunados de combatir al virus y su
nivel de coincidencia con los
anticuerpos de los jóvenes de 16 a 25
años y tenían altos niveles de
coincidencia en metz pericos la gigante
farmacéutica estadounidense explicó que
a los niños solo les administró una
tercera parte de la dosis que se usan
normalmente pero que la respuesta
inmunitaria fue igual de efectiva
fighter asegura que someterá el uso a
las autoridades reguladoras para finales
de mes la compañía defiende que el uso
de su fármaco devolvería a los más
pequeños la posibilidad de una crianza
en condiciones normales me gustaría
recordar a la gente que esto va más allá
de los niños que se enferman y tienen el
potencial de transmitir el virus a las
personas vulnerables sino que hablamos
de la manera como esto ha interrumpido
la vida normal de los niños y de que
puedan tener una educación cara a un
aprendizaje en persona y desarrollar
actividades dentro y fuera de la escuela
kaiser hizo el anuncio a través de un
comunicado de prensa y todavía debe dar
los detalles en una publicación
científica ciertos científicos
calificaron la noticia de esperanzadora
pero insistieron en que quieren ver más
evidencias antes de que se lleve a la
práctica
bueno si les parece dejamos eeuu y nos
vamos hasta argentina vamos a comenzar
por conocer cómo están las cifras en
este país en donde también hubo
novedades destacadas a lo largo de esta
semana sobre todo en torno a las
restricciones argentinas reporta para el
cierre de esta semana más de 5.2
millones de casos confirmados de kobe 19
las víctimas que ya deja el kobe 19 en
ese país superan las 114 mil la
población con tan sólo una dosis de
vacuna supera el 64 por ciento mientras
que el porcentaje de población que ya
tiene el esquema completo llega al 45
puntos 70 por ciento argentina ha ganado
terreno con la vacunación después de
varias dificultades y retrasos que tuvo
y acercará en las recientes semanas
y ya lo decíamos los argentinos ya
podrán salir a las calles sin tapabocas
van a poder ir a las discotecas oa los
boliches como se les conoce allí y más
importante aún van a poder acudir a los
estadios de fútbol eso sí con algunas
restricciones en el aforo un alivio para
este país que vivió uno de los
confinamientos más largos de la región
de américa latina están bajando las
cifras de contagio y también la de los
fallecidos el gobierno también usa esta
medida como un as bajo la manga de cara
a las elecciones legislativas de
noviembre y también con la llegada de la
primavera en el hemisferio austral y
también como una maniobra política
tenemos que decirlo después de las
elecciones primarias desde buenos aires
se conecta con nosotros natalio coso y
nuestro corresponsal en la capital
argentina natalia gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa y
levantaron algunas de las restricciones
cuáles se van a mantener y cómo han
recibido este anuncio los argentinos
si en este contexto de caída de los
contagios el gobierno anunció esta
semana que dejarán de regir ciertas
restricciones a partir del primero de
octubre por un lado ya no será necesario
utilizar barbijo tapaboca en las calles
si cuando hay aglomeraciones de personas
también anunció el gobierno que podrá
haber 100% de aforo de ocupación de
capacidad en todas las actividades
económicas también en eventos sociales
deportivos culturales religiosos a
puertas cerradas si manteniendo el uso
de barbijo en ese caso la distancia
entre las personas necesarias para
prevenir contagios y proveyendo una
ventilación adecuada
incluso se va a permitir el
funcionamiento de las discotecas con un
50 por ciento de aforo aún el gobierno
reconociendo que es una actividad
especialmente riesgosa y algo muy
importante esta semana el consejo
federal de educación que reúne a
ministros y secretarios de educación de
todas las provincias decidió que va a
intentar empezar a regresar a la
presencialidad plena en todos los
niveles educativos
importante esa decisión para los
estudiantes hallen argentina- natalio
pero también hubo anuncios en torno a
las medidas para los extranjeros que van
a argentina y para los ciudadanos
argentinos que están fuera del país y
que quieren regresar a este país
si a partir de este viernes quedaron
exceptuados de hacer cuarentena cuando
llegan al país los argentinos y
extranjeros residentes en el país
también personas que vienen por trabajo
y están especialmente autorizadas
siempre y cuando acrediten que han
completado su esquema de vacunación al
menos 14 días antes de ingresar también
tienen que tener un pc es pcr hecho
dentro de las 72 horas antes del viaje
hacer un test de antígenos al llegar al
país y otro test pcr entre 5 y 7 días
después de su arribo luego hoy hay
fechas tentativas para otro tipo de
aperturas de fronteras por un lado el
primero de octubre los viajeros de los
países limítrofes argentinas podrán
ingresar sin hacer aislamiento
seguramente con las mismas medidas
requeridas a partir de este viernes para
argentinos y residentes y se espera
también que puedan empezar a abrirse las
fronteras terrestres algo que pedían los
gobernadores de provincias limítrofes
con países vecinos otra novedad es que
se espera que a partir del primero de
noviembre puedan entrar al país todos
los extranjeros de nuevo pone esquema de
vacunación completo
se ha realizado antes de viajar por
ahora la novedad inmediata es la de los
argentinos y residentes en argentina que
pueden ingresar sin cuarentena
cumpliendo las condiciones previstas
queda claro en natalio también
importante hablar en este directo en
esta conexión sobre esa decisión de la
opc que permite que laboratorios de
argentina y de brasil desarrollen y
fabriquen vacunas no solamente para el
cob y 19 sino para otras enfermedades
todo esto previendo escenarios futuros
si fuera una decisión de la organización
panamericana de la salud de la
organización mundial de la salud que
eligieron un centro en brasil y otro en
argentina para empezar a desarrollar a
hacer transferencia de conocimiento y de
tecnología para empezar a desarrollar
vacunas de adn mensajero una tecnología
que es la que utilizan las vacunas de
facer y modernas contra kobe 19 en
argentina la empresa seleccionada para
este desarrollo es sinergium biotech y
el objetivo de este este proyecto de la
organización mundial de la salud tiene
que ver con ampliar la capacidad
productiva para proveer a la región de
vacunas incluso también para prepararse
para futuras emergencias y la
posibilidad de desarrollar vacunas para
otras enfermedades que puedan emerger
anuncio importante para la región de
américa latina- natalio muchas gracias
por este reporte desde la ciudad de
buenos aires- y vamos a seguir en
américa del sur vamos hasta bolivia en
donde la pandemia de kobe 19 ha dejado a
miles de menores de edad huérfanos
muchos de ellos han quedado bajo el
cuidado de familia por eso de algunos de
sus hermanos mayores pero el estado
boliviano busca diferentes maneras para
poder ayudarnos veamos
luís flores un joven de 22 años quedó a
cargo de ocho hermanos de entre 2 y 18
años tras la muerte de su madre ocurrida
hace un año por falta de atención médica
cuando sufría por varios males y los
hospitales estaban colapsados por la
pandemia la verdad y ha sido muy difícil
para mí muy difícil me tienen que alejar
de muchas cosas y olvidarme del impreza
de mí misma no contaminamos para apoyar
también a mis hermanos que estén bien
que estén tranquilos tal vez si se
hubiese salvado puede que no yo sólo
había sabe pero ya que nos atiende en el
momento no había ningún hospital la
defensoría del pueblo ha pedido al
parlamento aprobar varios beneficios
para los huérfanos de la pandemia como
subsidios económicos y prohibir que sus
tutores sean despedidos hemos visto que
en la realidad son los hermanos mayores
los que se están haciendo cargo y para
ellos era importante poder ayudarles con
de una fuente de empleo en algunos de
una situaciones de mayor precariedad de
la posibilidad de que se puedan
implementar programas de vivienda
la defensoría calcula que las ayudas
podrían beneficiar en principio a 1600
huérfanos pero en el parlamento ven
factibles sólo medidas que no impliquen
erogaciones altas de dinero por la
crisis económica otro problema es
identificar a los posibles beneficiarios
ya que no todas las muertes cuentan con
las certificaciones de kobe y mientras
el parlamento intenta resolver sus
propias dudas louis continúa trabajando
para atender a sus ocho hermanos porque
las ayudas todavía son inciertas
de bolivia nos vamos hasta brasil allí
el presidente bolsonaro en su discurso
ante el pleno de la organización de
naciones unidas habló sobre los planes
que ha desarrollado en su país para
hacer frente a la pandemia kobe 19
después de que la había negado durante
varios meses algunas de las cosas que
dijo incluso fueron calificadas como
mentiras para conocer más detalles vamos
hasta río de janeiro allí está valeriana
con en nuestra corresponsal que ya
regresó de unas merecidas vacaciones y
nos va a contar detalles de lo que dijo
el presidente bolsonaro durante su
el alocución su discurso allí en las
naciones unidas en nueva york
el viaje a nueva york- de jair bolsonaro
ha causado mucho revuelo especialmente
su discurso ante la onu tanto por las
imprecisiones de los datos aportados
como por el tono radical que parecía
querer agradar sobre todo a su base de
seguidores más fieles personaron negó
que se esté destruyendo la floresta
amazónica
aportando datos falsos también dijo que
no hay corrupción en su gobierno
obviando el caso de la vacuna kóvacs sin
comprarlas de forma fraudulenta a un
precio sobrevalorado y también ha
obviado la investigación policial que
salpica a dos de sus hijos políticos
también dijo que las manifestaciones del
7 de septiembre fueron las más grandes
que ha visto brasil en su historia lo
que no es verdad y finalmente volvió a
defender el llamado tratamiento precoz
contra el cobo y 19 basado en la hidroxi
cloroquina el medicamento que bolsonaro
defiende desde el inicio de la pandemia
y que no ha sido reconocido por la
comunidad científica
también ha sido muy criticado el gesto
el ministro de salud marcelo quiroga que
mostró el dedo medio a unos
manifestantes que estaban en la calle
protestando contra bolsonaro finalmente
la imagen del mandatario comiendo pizza
en la calle junto a las personas que le
acompañaban porque no estaba vacunado y
no podía acceder a los restaurantes de
nueva york también ha suscitado
muchísimas críticas
valeria y mire cómo es la vida el hijo
del presiente bolsonaro y también el
ministro de salud del que usted estaba
hablando fueron ya diagnosticados con
kobe 19
eduardo bolsonaro el hijo diputado del
presidente de brasil es la tercera
persona de la delegación brasileña a
nueva york que que contrae el
coronavirus eduardo ha aprovechado las
redes sociales para recordar que él sí
había sido vacunado de la fisher con la
primera dosis ha definido la importancia
de las vacunas y al mismo tiempo ha
vuelto a posicionarse contra el llamado
pasaporte sanitario diciendo que la
vacuna en el fondo no es garantía de
nada mientras su padre jair bolsonaro
está aislado hasta el fin de semana él
va a tener que demostrar que no tiene
corona virus y va a tener que repetir el
test hoy hemos sabido también que su
esposa michelle se vacunó en los eeuu
una decisión que ha sido fuertemente
criticada por los políticos y
epidemiólogos brasileños ellos dicen que
mitchell bolsonaro ha dado un mal
ejemplo demostrando que no confía en el
sistema sanitario de brasil mientras
tanto el ministro de salud marcelo
quiroga sigue haciendo cuarentena en un
hotel de nueva york en la prensa de
brasil ha informado que los cuartos de
este hotel de lujo juez mil dos mil
dólares y mientras tanto también la o no
está rastreando a todos los miembros de
la comitiva para saber con quién han
tenido relaciones sabemos que quiroga el
ministro de salud tuvo contacto con
muchos políticos y empresarios e incluso
con el primer ministro de inglaterra por
josh johnson al que estrechó la mano
brilloso se ha hecho un examen un test
de coronavirus atado negativo y mientras
tanto hemos sabido otra noticia que nada
tiene que ver con este viaje a nueva
york que también la ministra de
agricultura 3 a christina está con
coronavirus ella volvía de un viaje de
italia donde estuvo con los ministros de
agricultura del g20
bueno el gabinete de ministros bajo el
ataque del cob y 19 valeri para el
cierre hablemos de ese escándalo de
personas que en brasil recibieron
tratamientos médicos contra el kobe 19
que no estaban autorizados allí en este
país suramericano
la comisión parlamentaria que desde hace
meses investiga la gestión de la
pandemia de coronavirus ha destapado un
escándalo que salpica una seguro privado
de salud llamado prevent senior sus
médicos se serían obligados a prescribir
la hidroxi cloroquina y la invertir tim
a los dos medicamentos que constituyen
el polémico kit contra el coronavirus
defendido por el presidente yer
bolsonaro y cuya eficacia no ha sido
comprobada científicamente ha habido
reportajes en la televisión brasileña en
que estos médicos con la cara tapada
reconocen que eran obligados y hay una
sospecha de que hubo un plan secreto
para testar esos medicamentos en
ancianos sin el consentimiento de los
pacientes o de sus familiares además ha
habido otro escándalo paralelo un médico
de esta empresa antonio wong falleció
por complicaciones del coronavirus él
había usado la cloroquina sin embargo en
el certificado de muerte no aparece el
commit como causa y la sospecha de los
senadores que sea oculto la causa para
no manchar la imagen de la cloroquina
gracias valera por este reporte desde el
río de janeiro vamos a volver a eeuu en
donde tuvo lugar otro episodio de la
llamada diplomacia de las vacunas el
presidente joe biden anunció que
comprará 500 millones de dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 de la
farmacéutica pfiezer para donarlas a
países en vías de desarrollo
un acuerdo sin compromiso político así
calificó el presidente de eeuu o bailén
al anuncio que hizo de que su país
comprará y donará otras 500 millones de
dosis de la vacuna contra el cob y 19
elaborada por facer con ello la casa
blanca estaría duplicando su donación de
fármacos y espera que otras naciones se
sumen para disminuir el impacto de la
pandemia son nada sabemos que para
vencer a la pandemia aquí tenemos que
vencerla en todas partes mantengo la
promesa de que eeuu se convertirá en el
arsenal de vacunas como fuimos el
arsenal de la democracia durante la
segunda guerra mundial word show pero
será suficiente un documento de la ong
amnistía internacional señala las
principales farmacéuticas como
responsables de la desigualdad y la
escasez selectiva de vacunas al dirigir
gran parte de su producción a los países
ricos están sumiendo a algunas zonas de
latinoamérica áfrica y asia en nuevas
crisis llevando hacia el límite absoluto
a los debilitados sistemas de salud y
causando semanalmente decenas de muertes
evitables de acuerdo con datos de
working data casi seis mil millones de
dosis han sido aplicadas en el mundo
poco más del 43% de la población ha
recibido al menos una dosis y el 2% de
ellas en países de bajos ingresos en
eeuu de casi 300 90 millones de dosis
aplicadas solamente un 10% las recibió
la población afrodescendiente
a partir del mes de noviembre todos los
viajeros que estén totalmente vacunados
podrán ingresar a eeuu sin embargo se
les pedirá una prueba negativa una pcr
tres días antes antes de ingresar a este
país norteamericano
[Música]
bienvenidos a estados unidos el país
reabrirá sus puertas a partir de
noviembre a todos los pasajeros
extranjeros totalmente vacunados que
lleguen por vía aérea starting grant a
principios de noviembre pondremos en
marcha protocolos estrictos para
prevenir la propagación del cob el 19
por parte de los pasajeros de vuelos
internacionales a eeuu exigiendo que los
adultos extranjeros que viajen a eeuu
estén completamente vacunados además de
presentar un certificado de vacunación
contra el kobe 19 los viajeros tendrán
que someterse a una prueba tres días
antes de viajar a eeuu y respetar el
porte de mascarilla las compañías aéreas
también pondrán en marcha un sistema de
seguimiento de los viajeros la unión
europea acogió con satisfacción el
anuncio tras meses de una prohibición de
viajar que ha mantenido separadas a
miles de familias en los últimos 18
meses
un paso esperado desde hace mucho por
las familias y amigos separados y una
buena noticia para las empresas
seguiremos trabajando por la seguridad
de los viajes la decisión beneficia en
total a 33 países entre ellos brasil
india china iraní sudáfrica también fue
muy bien recibida por las aerolíneas que
presionaron a la casablanca durante
meses para que se levanten las
restricciones sin lograrlo a tiempo para
la temporada de viajes de verano si bien
las fronteras aéreas de la unión
americana se abren así para millones de
personas
washington extendió las restricciones en
sus fronteras terrestres los viajes son
esenciales como el turismo por parte de
extranjeros seguirán en vigor para
méxico y canadá al menos hasta el 21 de
octubre
el reino unido- simplificará las
restricciones de viajes desde y hacia
ese país europeo pero la totalidad de
los países de américa del sur y también
buena parte de centroamérica y el caribe
siguen estando en la llamada lista roja
es decir los países que van a seguir
teniendo complicadas restricciones para
ingresar o poder salir de ese país luisa
pulido desde el reino unido nos tiene
más detalles adelante a luís a
ahora que el reino unido ha empezado a
relajar sus restricciones de viajes
internacionales la pregunta que surge es
cuándo será posible volver a viajar a
américa latina y lo cierto es que no hay
una respuesta una fecha para el futuro
cercano dado que esta región se
encuentra toda en la lista roja de
viajes del gobierno británico es decir
que si se va a esa zona entonces cada
persona cada viajero debe permanecer y
hacer una cuarentena de 10 días en un
hotel cuyo valor es de más de 3.100
dólares incluso si se está completamente
vacunado con pzifer astrazéneca moderna
o jansen porque el gobierno británico no
reconoce las vacunas de esos
laboratorios que han sido aplicadas en
américa latina ni tampoco los
certificados de vacunas pero si lo hace
con esas mismas vacunas que han sido
aplicadas en otros países del mundo lo
que es considerado como
discriminatorio e injusto porque no se
conocen tampoco con claridad cuál ha
sido cuáles son los criterios
científicos para tomar esta decisión que
también afecta a áfrica y algunos países
asiáticos estas restricciones también
han causado un impacto en la industria
turística latina y británica dado que
américa latina es uno de los destinos
favoritos para quienes quieren escapar
del frío del invierno luisa muchas
gracias por este reporte desde el reino
unido- les cuento ahora brevemente otras
noticias destacadas a lo largo de esta
semana la vacunación pierde ritmo en
colombia y esto dificultará llegar a la
meta de tener inmunizada el 70% de la
población de este país para el fin de
este año la entrega irregular de los
lotes de vacunas de las farmacéuticas
que ha comprado colombia ha sido la
causa de esta lentitud y tener
vacunación completa contra el kobe 19 no
será obligatorio para ingresar a perú el
nuevo decreto indica que a partir de
ahora solo será necesario tener una
prueba molecular
y miren esta noticia el presidente de
austria alexander found der velden
anunció que su país donará 50 mil dosis
de la vacuna de astrazéneca contra el
cob y 19 a costa rica el anuncio tuvo
lugar durante la asamblea de la onu en
la ciudad de nueva york
y ahora demos un vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el hobby 19
que fueron destacadas en redes a lo
largo de esta semana el diario chicago
tribune titula 'el salvador' vacunar a
los niños menores o niños mayores mejor
de 6 años el inicio de este proceso de
vacunación lo anunció el presidente
salvadoreño nadie bukele el momento en
que las autoridades advirtieron por el
aumento de contagios y de fallecidos en
ese país en france24 punto con titulamos
presidentes latinoamericanos hablan de
la pandemia de kobe 19 ante la asamblea
de la onu un hecho ocurrido esta semana
los mandatarios llevaron temas
particulares de sus países pero también
coincidieron en abordar la gestión de la
pandemia otros abogaron por una
distribución mucho más equitativa de las
vacunas a nivel mundial y la agencia efe
titula uruguay suma su decimotercer día
del mes de septiembre sin muertos por
kobe 19 así lo confirmó el informe
diario del sistema nacional de
emergencias de ese país y confirmó que
solamente hubo 128 nuevos casos de
contagio en las últimas 24 horas
el pasado 21 de septiembre el hemisferio
sur dio la bienvenida a la primavera en
países como argentina la fecha es motivo
de celebración pero este año también
coincidió con el levantamiento de
algunas de las restricciones por la
pandemia natalio cosoi cara que ustedes
ya conocen aquí nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires- nos cuenta como los
argentinos ya pudieron tener esta
tradicional celebración el día de la
primavera o el día del amigo con un poco
más de libertad
este es el rosedal de palermo uno de los
parques más populares de la ciudad de
buenos aires todos los años muchas
personas vienen a celebrar aquí
especialmente el 21 de septiembre el día
de la primavera pero este es un año
especial porque finalmente después de
muchos meses de pandemia en las últimas
semanas comenzaron a descender
sostenidamente los casos los
fallecimientos por kobe 19 y también la
cantidad de gente internada en terapias
intensivas así que este 21 de septiembre
este día de la primavera es
particularmente especial yo en mi caso
personal pasé por el cobista así que es
como que es un renacer digamos es
disfrutar más que nunca el el día no con
los amigos y demás eso me pone muy feliz
poder salir tranquila y ya con vacuna y
todo es mucho mejor más cómodo se siente
salir sin miedo
mucha alegría pero también mucha
responsabilidad porque todo
no pasó lo del virus pero bueno los
chicos necesitan salir necesitan
disfrutar de un día por lo menos después
de tanto de un año y medio de
descripción este optimismo coincide este
mismo 21 de septiembre con el anuncio
por parte del gobierno de un progresivo
relajamiento de las medidas restrictivas
vinculadas con el coi 19 y así aparece
entonces la esperanza de que tal vez
argentina se esté acercando a la
posibilidad de dejar atrás esta pandemia
llega la primavera y llega al buen clima
es todo por el momento aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana con más noticias
destacadas de la semana en la pandemia
de kobe 19 nuestro continente siga con
france 24
[Música]